[Musique]
bonjour à l'elysée bonjour l'invasion
russe en ukraine fait évoluer les
pratiques de la guerre des belligérants
mais aussi des noms belligérants quelle
est la nouvelle approche américaine
alors une deux axes très clair on a bien
senti le basculement on va livrer là
pour le coup à l'ukraine un certain
nombre de matériaux militaires lourds
alors on a parlé d'obusiers très lo et
puis là si ça y est c'est quasiment
officiel également des avions de chasse
alors qu'on pense que ce serait
essentiellement 2029 donc ça c'est le
premier accès deuxième axe ou sans doute
les américains vont accentuer leurs
efforts des d'appui à l'armée
ukrainienne c'est le renseignement et là
ils vont fournir sans doute encore plus
de renseignements sur la problématique
du donbass c'est une nouveauté cette
cette approche américaine du
renseignement oui très clairement et
c'est sans doute le fruit d'une
réflexion qui ne date pas évidemment de
la sphère de l'ukraine puisque bien
avant la sphère de l'invasion de
l'ukraine en janvier avril heinz qui est
la directrice de la communauté du
renseignement américain a annoncé une
nouvelle stratégie kinski sachs que les
américains appellent le camping en gros
faire campagne c'est tout simplement de
faire en sorte de prendre du
renseignements classifiés et de le
déclassifiés c'est à dire de le
transporter dans le dans le public alors
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait avant la guerre
c'est eux qui annonçait que le conflit
aurait bien lieu etc ils sont sans doute
à aller beaucoup plus loin et d'ailleurs
moscou et pékin sont impressionnés quand
même par la qualité du renseignement
américain tel point de savoir s'il n'ya
même pas des agents très très très
infiltrée dans les milieux moscovite
toute la question que se posent
aujourd'hui le renseignement américain
sait jusqu'où jusqu'où on va donner des
informations précises et surtout
tactique c'est à dire des renseignements
tactique c'est à dire des
positionnements de troupes russes là ça
veut dire quand même qu'on engage quand
même un peu plus des forces armées
américaines dans ce conflit est ce qu'on
peut imaginer que cette nouvelle
doctrine soit utilisé dans le civil mais
c'est un peu toujours ce qui s'est passé
ce qu'on voit depuis la chute du mur de
berlin c'est qu'en effet une technique
une pratique dans le monde militaire et
basculer ensuite dans le monde civile il
ya eu des réflexions après la chute du
mur de berlin de la communauté du
renseignement américain sur qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des agents après tout ils ont
battu l'ours soviétique on les a
réorienté sur la possibilité de faire du
renseignement économique est là aussi va
se poser la question est ce que la
qualité du renseignement est connu rep
un acquis par les américains est-ce que
là aussi ça n'a pas passé dans le civil
toujours avec le même but défendre des
intérêts des états unis et en france est
ce qu on est préparé pour ce nouveau
front alors d'abord on nous dit qu'en
france on est quand même le deuxième
contributeur en matière de renseignement
au sein de l'otan c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même des capacités de
renseignement importante de la france
mais évidemment c'est une question de
mentalité on n'y est pas encore un déjà
communiqué de la part des services des
renseignements avec le public c'est
difficile mais là toute une réflexion
sur comment déclassifie des
renseignements issus des services de
sécurité c'est difficile mais un pas a
été franchi en octobre avec la nouvelle
doctrine dont a parlé le chef d'état
major des armées le général burkhardt sa
nouvelle doctrine c'est gagner la guerre
avant la guerre ça signifie donc que les
armes et se repositionne sur la guerre
de l'information
merci beaucoup